honored lawn gene watches have 110
world's fair grand prizes twenty eight
gold medals and more honors for accuracy
than any other timepiece launching the
world's most honored watch is made in
guaranteed by the lawn gene with no
watch company it's time for the
launching horoscope a television journal
of the important issues of the hour
brought to you every Monday Wednesday
and Friday a presentation of the lawn
gene which Noir Watts company maker of
launching the world's most honored watch
and wit nor distinguished companion to
the world honored lawn gene seizing this
is Frank Knight may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the
launching horoscope mr. William Bradford
Huie editor of the american mercury and
mr. Henry Hazlitt editor of the freeman
and contributing editor of newsweek
magazine our distinguished for this
evening is the honorable john foster
dulles united states ambassador at large
the opinions expressed airily those of
the speakers mr. Dulles you are known to
all Americans as the chief architect and
representative of the bipartisan foreign
policy and as the man who's done most to
shape the Japanese peace treaty now my
understanding is that most of your
official work in connection with that
treaty is over and that your present
activities are mainly concerned with
acting as consultant to members of the
Senate who want to ask questions about
the treaty is that about right yeah
that's about right mr. Isaac we worked
for a year negotiating the treaty then
it was signed by 49 nations now we've
had the hearings before the Senate
Foreign Relations Committee we worked
out a declaration that the treaty does
not in any way give effect to the yamen
agreement which some people fear it
might be the case
the treaties been recommended by a 13 to
nothing vote by the fire relations
committee not a wait Senate action I'm
available to for consultation with any
senator you want to talk about it well
with a 13 to nothing vote from the
committee it looks as if the prospects
for endorsement for ratification are
pretty bright well I think so too I like
to think so
but we've had good Senate backing all
the way through because from the very
beginning I have felt that the senator
should be brought in on the consultation
with us and we've had consultation from
the beginning it isn't a case to just
bring him in at the end mr. Dulles you
have a splendid reputation for
objectivity among most Americans and I'm
sure that our audience tonight would
like your views on the general oil
situation now sir in your opinion are we
stronger this year as against Russia
than we were last year I think probably
not it's pretty hard to judge those
things but my estimate would be that the
tide is still running against us
everywhere I look around the world the
question is what maybe we're going to
lose next you know and we seem to be on
the defensive and that they're on the
offensive the question is what are we
going to lose each year more than what
are we going to gain you can look around
the whole circle of the world and you
find one spot after another after
another after another where the question
is are we going to lose this better the
free world is it going to be Iran or is
it going to be Egypt or is going to be
Indochina or is it going to be Korea or
what's it going to be now people who
have been in this position for so long
and it seems so hopeless and it's been
so much negativism now sir do you see
any way by which we can reverse this
process so that we can gain hope again
in America all right absolutely and
convinced that we can do it and how
could we do that say well we've been
entirely negative in our approach we've
lost a good old-fashioned American
dynamism when we were a little nation
and just we're getting started we stood
for something with so vital and so
dramatic and exciting in the world that
everybody everywhere wanted to follow
our example we were the dynamic force in
the world and then the despots were all
wondering what they were going to lose
next and then you had a terrific
despotism again led by Russian leaders
in useful to remember tsar alexander was
a great most powerful potentate in the
world and his power stretched all around
the world down into Mexico into South
America and what happened then the
question was what they were going to
lose and they finally were driven back
back and back we can recapture that
American spirit well mr. Dulles what
specifically would you recommend doing
let's say in China take a specific
example what do you think we ought to do
concretely now in regard to China the
first thing is to make clear as I said
testifying before the Senate Foreign
Relations Committee that we have a
positive policy that we do not accept
this permanent this common ization of
the Chinese mainland good many people
out there wonder about that they're not
quite convinced as to what our really
intentions are many people who would be
with us a lying low because they don't
really trust our intentions adequately
we must care up that doubt and make
clear what our intentions are then
opportunity after opportunity will be
created month which by such actions as
sending help to the guerrilla forces on
the mainland and getting further help to
Shanghai shek I believe that we should
give help and comfort to people anywhere
tickly in China I don't say particular
in China you're asking me about China
who are resistant to communism I don't
think we want to have a war because a
war is a thing upon which come nism
thrives and breeds but we certainly can
give the thing which is needed most of
all is moral aid and comfort how you
talk to these people I've talked to
selling them you take the Nationalists
on the Formosa the thing they need most
is moral support more even than economic
aid or even in material aid we
giving a considerable amount of material
and economic military and economic aid
there the thing is lacking is the
quality I would try to bring in which is
more of a a hopeful purposeful spirit of
dynamism they want to be sure were on
their side you want to be they want to
be sure on their side and they want the
the moral comfort that comes with that I
I believe it was Tom Paine who wants a
contributed the statement that the cause
of America is the cause of mankind do
you think it might be hopeful if we
would start with a declaration that we
Americans are going to aid the cause of
freedom throughout the world again I
think it sir well time that we should
make that clear again as long as we
stood for that in the world we were on
the offensive the despot on the
defensive we were secure during that
hundred years there was no peril of this
country we've only begun to have our
peril during the last fifty years when
we've become rich and strong and fat and
more interested in keeping the things we
had than in giving other people freedom
that's the danger point for us well mr.
Dulles I'd like to get back to some
specific questions on this Japanese
peace treaty now one thing that's been
one question that's been raised is this
it's been feared that the Japanese will
very much need trade with China and
because of this need for trade that
they'll be tempted to recognize and deal
with the Chinese Communists do you have
any comment to make on that yes so the
you've got 85 million people almost on
Japan for the barren Islands they can't
grow their own food or their own
material for clothing or anything of
that sort they got to live some way now
there's plenty of opportunities for them
to live and to live well in trade with
Southeast Asia and other parts of the
world they don't have to trade with
China they have not trade with China for
the last five years two-month anything
and they've improved their economic
condition tremendously now if the free
world is irresponsible and cuts Japan
out from all their markets
then the Japanese will be faced with a
hard choice he'll either have to play
along with communism or starve to death
they don't like come nism they hate
Russia they don't want to do it and they
will not do it unless I think
irresponsible economic policy by the
free nations virtually kicked them into
the arms of the comments mr. Dulles you
once again coming back to your
reputation for objectivity you've had
perhaps the best chance to study the
results that we have obtained in Japan
through five years of occupation policy
specifically you studied carefully the
record of General MacArthur now would
you like to give our audience your
appraisal of General MacArthur's work in
the Orient yes I think that he did a
perfectly amazing job in Japan they
never in history been an occupation
which has been as fruitful as that was
he combined magnanimity with with
justice he gained the respect to the
people and he brought the Japanese
people along very far I think on the
road of being genuine self-governing
people he introduced many reforms
thought about the land reform the
Communists the land reforms the
MacArthur put through in Japan were
instantly superior to anything has been
done in the communist countries and a
good bill of rights and labor unions
beginning to take hold than an amazing
job and he inspired this peace treaty we
never would have had this peace treaty
if you talked about it John MacArthur
when I was over there with the Secretary
of Defense Johnson who was in the
Secretary of Defense and Gerald Bradley
in June 950 it was a talks that we had
there general McArthur and MacArthur's
conviction that the occupation had come
to its normal end and we should give the
Japanese back their freedom independence
that is the thing that inspired this
victory we were speaking of our
bipartisanship again so you think that
as a nation we might very well take
bipartisan pride in what we did in in
Japan during those five years it's a
magnificent record that we can be proud
of mr. Dulles because we own this
program
so much that's not hopeful I would like
for us to come back again to this point
do you expect that we Americans can do
something hopeful and do you think that
we will do something hopeful for the
world in the way of enunciated a new
policy I'm not totally convinced mr. joy
that we can't we've been looking at this
whole world picture through the wrong
end of the telescope we just see our own
troubles our own weaknesses and the
other fella looks strong and solid and
invulnerable but if we turn the
telescope around and look at it the
right way we would see the amazing
resources that we have the hope that we
can inspire in people we would say the
oppression of the despotism there the
fact that even within Russia there 15
million people in captive prison camps
they only ruled by terrorism why that
situation ought to be a pushover would
have been a pushover in the old days
Lumis the Dulles I'm sure that our
audience very much appreciates this
hopeful message of yours thank you sir
for being with us the editorial board
for this edition of the launching CONUS
Cove was mr. William Bradford Huie and
mr. Henry Hazlitt our distinguished
guests was the honorable john foster
dulles united states ambassador at large